warning if you're sensitive to bright
lights and flashing colors don't watch
this video it's kind of [ __ ] up
[Music]
and she's funny she bother her she hurt
opposition chamber you me and thought
would funny the hallway may shake
aficionado Bishop a treat or [ __ ] we
are such a favorable she made him hard
even for fashion okay hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to let's
play sluggish Moors why anything else
you want to bring hurry on this is like
the most I've ever seen both of us here
yes both of us not just one of us we
both lots in common with the toys what
do you think you would be if you didn't
get any of the toys you would be way
behind we would be waiting here for
agents until it's Christmas time and
then still you still probably wouldn't
even be here hug but we have people not
remember keep your eyes on the prize ESP
price on the prize good night okay so
keep eyes on the prize what the hell
happened uh even now but this is weird
is this even a game
okay that's still backwards
welcome to falafel sluggish more it's
okay so we're finally at the namesake of
the game game hi oh I'm playing now I
think I think this is me playing I don't
know what I'm doing
[Music]
this game is imperceptibly strange I
don't even know why this is one of those
games where of the I say I like the
vision of the game wow I don't take your
coin [ __ ] no yeah okay alright so this
is an example of a game where where I
say a lot of the artistic vision of the
maker has gone terribly wrong the world
[Music]
why I make any damn sense down down down
down down down down down what was that
baby looking thing okay I'm gonna take a
wild stab at this this is the peering
into the reality inside do like Prada or
something I don't know
I noticed there's a lot of circuit
boards but the job is simple but dull
didn't you bring any nice reggae tracks
on board did you oh no you guys seem to
have a pension what's going on with you
guys seem to enjoy smoking a bit and I'm
collecting coins maybe it's a play on
life's pursuit of material goods and
wealth those that you can I don't know 5
years 4 days 3 hours and 22 minutes
until docking procedure must be
initiated
what somebody need to put a seizure
warning at the beginning of this video I
still had a complete loss I mean I think
that's Japanese I'm hearing but I'm not
exactly sure ello keeps coming back to
last encounter with someone he's been
dating since 10 days ago for you to
bring him I'm collecting it Wow I used
to be an artist do you want to see my wa
it involves getting coin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell was that you ever seen a
rat around here yes I have
Hey look money yay Hey look more money
it's just falling from the sky oh I
remember floating towards a binary
system live it was a big orange Sun in a
small blue one it was pretty please take
these four coins you'll need them for
one I still don't know what did you hear
the captain won okay I'm gonna stop
acting like I'm surprised at what I'm
about to see because obviously I'm not
meant to understand any of this it's all
just one big what the hell is going on I
rat I don't want to see well I'm leaving
Byron I'm leaving are we witnessing the
witnesses of one taking a stroll in a
row hi
[Music]
[Applause]
ah hi I strange Buddha hi guy what I the
universe is involved within itself yet
the Sun involves our planet is assistant
have ever existed while stars cease to
have ever existed yet no planets no
stars nothing the other last thought not
our most recent memory is the only
massive existence our mind travels
infinite life years yes yes it does your
death establishes space-time here you
are you are here ok this has been a bad
trip in the all these guys just seem
like they're all boy not this again Oh
much more pleasant music this time well
this is actually nice no no it's not
none of this has been nice for damn sure
none of this has been any sort of nice
saw just one big freaky adventure but I
never want to relive again maybe these
aren't actually coins maybe they're like
pills never thought about bad just
sitting alone wasting away my life and
for what I can't move anymore
[Laughter]
hi hey you guys have you ever looked up
at his stores and wondered what is oh
they're stars
will I ever be able to go to the stars
let me tell you space isn't a nice place
and good things will happen to you yes
it isn't the best place to be up there
in space but it looks like you've gotten
yourself into some kind of strange
little that you can't get out of which
may lead to some strange experiences
hopefully the coins are familiar and
will help you to it will make the
experience hi
[Music]
I can't do anything your spirit has now
left the body and you are safe good
night good night good night
okay that was weird this is the end of
the game this is incredibly strange and
what is this now I'm flying fly there's
magical adventure everything you
experience it is accessed from your mind
you can make any decision you want
do not worry time is irrelevant what you
call time is only normal second before
you're dead and I can see in this yes he
is right and saying this being careful
you can what you might think speed
things up and evolution created in your
mind there is no such thing as time here
he has no such thing as time I feel we
must do that in your head okay so you
okay
I still don't get it we experienced the
time you think you experience more candy
were very patient but this experience
isn't about us were only here to make it
worth your non-existent while okay and
now we must we must
[Music]
it's the whole gang we're back ah it's
so good to see you guys my old friends
why are you all staring at me like that
[Music]
this game is just so beyond messed up
I'm just trying to see if there's an
ending I don't get it I don't get it I
do not get it I don't even know if
there's anything to get I really don't
know I just don't know is this the end
of the game nope I'm still in the same
place I was you know how I shot you in
the head I take it back please come back
what I think I've been making the same
face throughout this whole video just
[Music]
I've got no commentary to say about this
game there's really nothing that I can
say it's just total insanity so I just
don't know I do not know I don't know I
[Music]
don't know there's got to be an end
there's got to be an edge something is
this please tell me it's the end I'm
ready to get off this ride hello am I
done I want to go home I want to go home
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I guess that's it I guess we are
officially done so that was that and
that was weird um weird as hell don't
even know what I'm gonna do with this
video so oh man I guess thanks for
watching I have nothing I don't
recommend this game to any excuse me to
anyone this is weird alright anyway so
I'm all done here so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]